[Musique]
alors j'essaie michel si nous avons
montré un extrait d roi d'yvetot ce
n'était pas par hasard et gratuitement
avant parce que l'airé un curé oui il y
avait un curé formidable s'est tue si
j'ai eu la chance comme je le disais
tout à l'heure j'ai managé d'un
formidable et j'ai rencontré un curé qui
m'a fait croire en dieu ce qui est pas
ce qui n'est pas toujours vrai c'est un
vrai curé je pense que si lui existe
c'est que dieu existe
je parle très sérieusement cet homme là
pour moi c'est la bonté c'est là la
pauvreté c'est le dévouement
c'est la gentillesse à l'état pur c'est
le talent c'est un tu l'a retrouvé c'est
le quatrième tableaux de la vie de
michel sardou s'est accusé une bagnole
si on peut dire avec
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avec jackie sardou labbé vice la maman
[Musique]
ok
il est bien de lui même et vous mettre
la rate au bas du dos la lamelle falloir
qu'on fasse attention la tension entre
l'adulte en carbone et venez manager
n'est pas là
jean-pierre voie libre inquiétez pas
l'image qu'on s'assoit tous les ans ça
sera laissé à tous vous inquiétez pas je
me sens tout petit oui je suis très ému
je suis très ému ce que je disais de de
le retrouver on s'est revus bien sûr on
s'est revus à marseille a pas longtemps
mais c'est un curé formidable c'est un
curé de pagnol c'est un curé c'est le
curé de cucugnan avec beaucoup de coeur
avec beaucoup de gentillesse
je me suis marié 24 ans après l'église
parce que ton père de marc amener amp a
raconté sa vie avait oublié de me dire
qu'il ne s'était pas appelé sardou tout
de suite au départ ah bon je demandais
comme ceux demandés partout l'acte de
baptême de mon mari sous le nom de
fernand sardou envisageons madame y
apprend comment il s'appelait plantain
tu as manqué d'appeler mon cher
[Applaudissements]
c'est parce tout sa première fois que
nous apprenons salle on paye ça faisait
bande à père qui faisait bien les choses
n'avaient pas reconnu son pistolet
l'arrivée
[Applaudissements]
j'entends mon père et fils de la bonne
tu te mettes appelé michel plantain et
ben écoute ça va bien et puis il ya les
c'est la bonne la rue monge moi souffle
aussi c'est que ton père m'a toujours
raconté qu'il était né dans la salle des
pas perdus de la gare david oui ça je
savais ça oui alors qu'ils demandent
quand quelqu'un est né dans la salle des
pas perdus de la gare d'avignon va
prouver son esprit de baptême avec ça
alors il m'a dit débrouille toi maman
voyait tout de suite son essai de
baptême l'était parisiennes et les
parisiens vont mener les choses comme ça
et moi je suis partie sur ma bulle dans
les rues d'avignon comme la mule de
données tu sais la mule du pape
bien sûr et je fais toutes les paroisses
où il m'avait pas dit qu'il habitait à
ses rues j'ai appris par le livre
merveilleux que je recommande à tous tes
amis de lire les sardes ou de père en
fils et la pub au plus près de la vie
maintenant sur téva spot publicitaire
par la mairesse ce pas messieurs par de
la pub que de recommander le livre d'une
famille provençal à paris dit ça quand
même
les méridionaux y en a partout on me l'a
quand même qui m'a surpris en apprenant
que mon père était le fils de la bonne
quand même qu'il avait sauté la bonne
hello